Oh Ultron his pits we know this because
he's gone full Pinocchio quote so a
teaser trailer for age of Ultron has
either leaks or been released onto the
Internet I think the leads because it
was announced all right next Tuesday is
gonna be the age of Ultron trailer and
if you knew what I do you try to plot
out your week so I was like I get to
relax today celebrate my brother's
birthday with them it'll be good
nothing's happening today okay it's not
age of Ultron trailer better talk about
that
mostly because I want to talk about age
of Ultron looks awesome and at first
Ultron it shows him come basically looks
like a busted down piece of stark Tech
he's one of those radio-controlled Iron
Man suits and he comes out he's like
you'll have streams he crushes an Iron
Man mask you're like you're all in deep
[ __ ] I didn't notice it until I watched
the trailer a second time the music
starts in the trailer and it is the
participant ochio song I got no strings
to hold me down there's like this really
cool creepy version of it I love stuff
like that I like it when movies and
trailers do a song that you remember
from being nice and peaceful and fun and
family-friendly and give it a dark ass
edge to it like here's a scene that just
shouldn't go with that but it does I can
face off and that shootout happens like
so it's a teaser trailer so they're not
going to show you anything other than
imagery but I just love it I love the
James Spader voice energy and spanner
was gonna be all trials like kiyah as
what we call perfect on every level
he shows Iron Man in his what I believe
is the actual Hulkbuster armor
yeah we saw Iron Man 3 we're like a look
at Hulkbuster armor guess not this is
actually full Hulkbuster armor looks
like Hulkbuster armor and he's fighting
the Hulk
couldn't make a judgment call here it
shows Scarlet Witch and Quicksilver for
quicksupport Quicksilver I hope you have
a scene that's cooler than the kitchen
scene from x-men Days of Future past
otherwise we're going to be talking
about Quicksilver from x-men Days of
Future past
poor bastard it's Tony Stark I feel bad
for because he's like yeah I know I
didn't mean shows for like picking him
up by the neck you know he's like Tony
Stark you have failed this world and
thunder blows them up and he's not gonna
you know he's a little more than pissed
though he's the protector of Earth and
[ __ ] I love the end of this trailer
that's how you end a trailer like this
you show a busted ass Captain America
shield straight up caps shield broken
the [ __ ] in half and you hear James
Spader as Ultron goat now you see I've
got no strings on me damn
that thunder go to the title of the
teaser trailer of this movie this week I
was like whoa you're all in Beebe [ __ ]
if I wasn't earth I'd be like Nick Fury
Captain America someone commit capped
yes Oh Thank You Kat yeah
Ultron's pissed that's right sir he's
gone singing full Pinocchio I agree sir
we have to neutralize this threat right
now before he starts singing Rob
Zombie's super beast absolutely [ __ ]
kids bad I love the metaphor too it's
like I got no strings on me cuz I'm a I
you know the folks at marvel studios are
like sorry Terminator Genisys with a why
can't use that song in your trailer we
did it first
dammit the stupid novels like hey Zul
that's exactly how the conversation is
going right now what is this age of
Ultron trailer came a week before I was
expecting it and it looks pretty sweet
I like next-level [ __ ] Tony Stark
creating an AI that's going to destroy
the world that's rats like Tony Stark is
the Miles Bennett Dyson from Terminator
2 but we get to see exactly his mindset
when the shit's going down I could
speculate for days but I want to hear
what you think about it so the age of
Ultron teaser trailer have you seen it
what did you think about it every
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]